最近有很多投资朋友都跟我反馈说
投资交易中最让人头疼的
就是总是判断不清真假突破
账户亏损的一半基本都舍在这个问题上
到底有没有这样一个方法
既简单又能有效的帮助我们去判断真假突破呢
今天要讲的是用一个指标分辨真假突破
那这个指标是什么呢
我们先看这张图
价格一直在这个横盘区间内运行
如果从K线上找突破
可以看到A B C三个突破点
同样都是突破
但A和B突破后又很快回落了
属于假突破
而C突破后迅速上涨了一大波幅度
那我们怎么才能在它后面走出来之前
就知道真假突破呢
所谓量在乍先
也就是说成交量会走在价格的前面
在价格突破之前
量上面会提前给出突破点
而神奇的指标OBV能量潮就能帮助到我们
它是专门用来观察成交量的指标
所以回到这个图
K线的这条紧线同样在OBV上画一条
之后我们再看AB两处假突破
可以看到OPV的压力位没有冲上去
再看C处为什么是有效突破呢
因为它下面的OPV其实在这里就已经提前突破了
所以咱们才能知道C处的突破才是真正的突破稳稳的收获一大波利润这个时候有投资朋友会问OPV在前面这个高点的地方也突破了颈线位
这里的价格后面怎么也是下跌呢
注意好
OPV对应的价格的高点是没有突破前面的颈线位的
所以也谈不上增加突破了
还没有学会
再来看一个案例
同样的上面的K线前期也是在一个横板区间内运行
价格有过AB两次突破
很明显A突破后迅速回落是假突破
而B处突破后价格大幅上涨是真突破
但是在后面价格走出来之前
单纯看K线是很难看出来真假突破的
这个时候我们看一下OBV指标
是不是就可以清楚的看到
OPV在A点是没有突破颈线位的
而在B点价格突破之前
OPV指标就已经提前突破了
现在学会了吗
当然大家现在看到的这个OPV
是我精心改良过参数的
独此一份
关于我这个改良过的OPV参数的详细的设置方法
在评论区回复OPV参数即可获得
最后我们做一个总结
第一点K线近期处于横坛区域
第二点我们要标出K线和对应的OBV的紧线位
第三点观察OBV突破紧线位是不是先于K线突破
做到量再价先
好了这期视频咱们就先讲到这里
更多的技术分析干货外汇数字币交易信号
欢迎加入我的Telegram Channel
X-Channel官方中文群
我们下期再见
拜拜